so
so uh there aren't many things in life
that i really enjoy more than good
healthy broken code um i mean it's kind
of something that we experience in our
day-to-day lives all the time there's
nothing that we're ever gonna do to
write 100 perfect code um it's
inevitable that we're going to be
shipping things that are broken so it's
inevitable that we're going to have to
debug these things uh we're gonna debug
them in production we're gonna have to
you know do whatever it is that we do to
to fix these things
so who am i that light just got really
bright
uh my name is matt rovenalt um
i am the lead operations engineer at
discuss so first of all does anybody
know what discuss is
a few people cool
uh i would like to note that i do not
write javascript for disqus
i am an operations engineer
i got roped into doing this with a
project called sentry
sentry is an error aggregation and an
error logging service
it's an open source project that
originally came out of python and it has
since evolved into
us being able to aggregate exceptions
from ruby python erlang go and
javascript
so i came onto this thinking that
the javascript client at the time was
really really poor and i figured well
this can't actually be that hard i might
as well just go at it and try to fix all
the problems little did i know that uh
browsers are really really really
terrible at doing these types of things
so kind of before i go into things i
kind of want to kick it off by
this little funny excerpt that i thought
of and i thought of uh
if an exception happens in production
and nobody saw the chrome debug console
did it actually happen
um
this is kind of something that happens
all the time you know we ship production
code all of our tests passed things were
fine
until users start complaining and we
have no idea why this actually happened
um
we call this postmortem debugging
so for people that aren't familiar
post-mortem debugging is the concept of
uh
an exception has happened we don't have
the information at the time but we need
some way to uh
figure out what happened and debug it
after after the fact
so to go with postmodern debugging um
ideally we would like to know that these
things happen before users start
complaining to us uh that's not a great
user experience people are reporting
things are broken and whatnot um we like
to be able to stay on top of these
things and know that these things happen
before they have to tell us
in an ideal world these things would be
covered by tests right we would write
our tests we would cover every test case
we would tdd the out of everything
and everything would be perfect and fine
in reality humans are actually really
hard at writing tests and this is due to
a factor a large number of things um
with those being we don't know all the
we don't know all the test cases we
can't anticipate that our users are
going to do something really really
really stupid that we didn't think about
users are going to click a button 8
million times thinking that it's not
working but we didn't anticipate that
that's going to happen they're going to
have some crazy
combination of browser extensions and
all this other stuff that who knows what
they're doing
a lot of times we actually don't get
tests at all so that's that's the other
side of things we could be as meticulous
as we want and write all these tests
but in reality most things actually
don't even have tests so it's that
doesn't help us at all
also qa processes are faulty for
basically the same reason why writing
tests are pretty faulty so
there's all the combinations of browsers
um qa teams are expensive you know
there's a lot of different cases you
have to test at the end of the day
you're still not going to do everything
that every single user is going to test
users are your best qa team they're the
ones that are going to figure out what's
broken they're going to do they're going
to touch everything that you didn't even
think was possible
and no matter what you do bugs are still
going to get into production there's
just nothing good about nothing you're
gonna be able to do about it uh we
should just have better tooling to get
around this and deal with these issues
so if you guys work on a product that
users are using um if you're fortunate
enough to have customer support or
someone just emails you and says
something's broken
typically you get something like this
you get someone that's angry and irate
just says it doesn't work for me
well
what do you want me to do about it
so we look at and if we're fortunate
enough and we have an actual tech savvy
user we can maybe get a screenshot of
their chrome console we can somehow
coerce them into opening this up
reproducing the bug and we can maybe get
a screenshot of something like this
this is probably the best case that we
can get out of
postmortem debugging
without doing anything fancy
so it ends up turning into actually a
lot of this
it works for me i'm not going to fix
this because i don't know how to debug
your problem
and our users usually can't give us
enough information to
help us fix this
so how do we begin to be more proactive
about this like i said at the beginning
we want to be able to stay on top of
this if we want to be able to
know these things before our users are
actually telling us we don't want to
rely on them doing faulty screenshots
and all this stuff to tell us
here's what happened we don't want these
reproduction steps we want to actually
see
uh what happened in real time we want to
see what
the stack trace is and all the
information in the context
so we should start capturing our errors
and we start logging as much information
automatically so that we can debug we
can get notified of these errors we can
track these on graphs we could do all of
this information in real time on behalf
of our users before they start
complaining and telling us that you know
something's broken
so let's start with the most obvious way
of doing this this one is my absolute
favorite
so i'm sure we're all aware of this
window.on-error thing
um if you're not the cldr is the
window.niner is a global callback
that is effectively a try catch over
your entire application
i also call it window.on nope um
it's literally the worst way to capture
an exception that you can imagine um
the signature of the callback looks
something like this so it takes three
arguments the first one being a message
the url of the file that caused the
exception and then the line number
in reality you usually end up getting
this cryptic script error message
if any of you have seen that before
trying to debug things
i will explain what that is uh in more
detail in a second
um so kind of the problem with all this
is that out of these three arguments
that we saw none of these are an actual
error object
they're just a message url and a line
number
so in practice these three arguments end
up looking something like this we have
some type error we cannot read property
foo of undefined we have the url that
happened we have the line number
at a glance this actually looks really
useful we can we can drill under our
code we can see what is line 10 oh this
line you know something was probably
faulty here and we've we may have solved
we may be able to solve the problem with
this
but your code is actually probably
minified
line one is your entire application
you have a million characters on this
one really really long line
also your javascript is likely being
hosted on another domain so we're
talking a cdn or some extra sub domain
or a cookie list domain or something
like that
the problem with that is that
these these window denominators subject
to cores so for the cross origin request
scripting
and what that means is when it gets the
window donator or you get is
ben shaking i said it's something like
that it's crossovers and something
resource here
whatever
but in the end what this actually means
for you is you get script there so if
you have your javascript on a sub domain
or a cdn or something that is uh
doesn't have the proper course headers
and all the stuff to go with that
windowed auditor does not actually tell
you anything it tells you script there
line zero and an empty url
so you have literally no idea what
happened just that something happened
though in newer versions of browsers
specifically gecko 31 in firefox and
chrome 28 started introducing um
a more expanded version of window.onair
what this looks like is they've given
you two new arguments or two arguments
that are passed through there's a column
number and then an error object that's
passed through
now we have our error object
so i've been talking about these error
objects uh well why why are they so
important why is this better to work
with than an actual
uh the string message why is this better
than that generic type error
first of all we get a stack trace from
this
or we can try to
and for those that aren't aware
stacktrace is just a record of the
function calls
up until this point within the current
call stack so it's a sequence of
function calls you've called a a calls b
a calls or b call c and what not down
through uh what they call as a call
stack
basically when you're debugging
something if you don't have a stack
trace it makes things really really
difficult um it's probably a little bit
more difficult to dig into the error
because you see you can maybe see that
this exception happened at this line but
you don't know how you actually got to
that line you don't know what function
called that function you don't know the
order of events that
preceded that
so to explore this we're going to open
up our favorite executable
node
and we're just going to simply throw a
new error with the the message law
sure everybody has seen something like
this this is what comes back when you
just when you just arbitrarily throw and
do not catch an exception
so i'm going to break down what what
these individual pieces are
so the beginning we have the name so in
this case we just threw
a generic error this would also be a
type error or reference error or
something like that
and then we have the message so this
would be that long something is
undefined or whatever in this case we
just pass the lull
then below that we have the actual stack
trace
so we can break down the stack trees
into frames
so each line of the stack trace
gives us very useful information
so we have a caller this is the function
that was uh this is the function of that
frame
this is the source that that
function was called in so this case was
events.js
the line number this came from so line
95 and the column number
so for fun we have we now have this
property off of
the error prototype dot stack
for fun does anybody know what this the
actual type of error.stack actually is
it is a string probably the most useless
thing that you can get back from this
um so the way if you want to start
breaking this apart and you want to
extract the pieces out of it you need to
use a regular expression something like
this
and this is also note this is very
specific for a v8 stack trace
so this is kind of what's this begin to
look like in practice so here i've
written some really bad code
um we can see that we have a function
show thing
this show thing takes an arbitrary index
as an argument we expect this index to
exist in this arbitrary things array and
we're calling the foo property on it
as we could probably denote if we call
the show thing one
the result of things index is going to
be undefined
and undefined does not have a property
foo
so we fire up node again and we want to
actually execute this we will see it
does in fact throw a type error
and to go with that we can see this this
very useful stack trace so we see that
type error cannot read property blah
blah blah but then we see right below
that
we can see that it was within the show
thing function so within that show thing
function it also tells us exactly what
line number it happened actually exactly
what column number
uh raised the exception
and then if we keep traversing down the
stack we see line 12
which was exactly where show thing was
called it had it's an anonymous function
so it doesn't have a name in in the call
stack
if you also note firefox
does something very drastically
different um it's the same concept you
still have the stack property but since
it's a string
these things are formatted completely
different
so there is no standard around how these
stack traces are formatted so if we were
to write something that extracted all of
these different components and all these
things for different browsers also note
this changes per version of browser
so this is not even just all of firefox
this is you know firefox 14 versus
firefox 25 versus whatever
same for chrome same for safari all
these things are different formats so if
we were to write something we have to
write a bunch of crazy regular
expressions to capture all of these
different cases and we have to also sort
of feature detect to determine which
ones are going to give us this type of
stack trace
so now if we go into ugly or minifying
our code
if we minify that exact code we end up
with something like this
um it should be relatively parsable it's
pretty small but we can see that through
minification we've we've removed all the
white space and we've also shortened our
symbol names
so in this case if we look closely
there's a function n this this signifies
what show thing was previously
so if we run this again we indeed get
the exact same
exception
except now we get line one column 125.
this now gets a little bit more
complicated to debug and figure out
what's going on right
in this case it's probably still kind of
deductible but we only have
basically one function in play if this
was our application this might actually
be column 20 000.
we also see in the stack it happened at
function n
what is n there could be multiple ends
now through minification we have no idea
what's what's actually happening here
we're very clueless at this point this
is how things are shipped in production
usually
so something was invented uh source maps
i'm not sure of the exact purpose that
these were invented for probably with
coffeescript and all this other stuff
but
the fact of the matter is we now have
these source maps and these source maps
are
it's a map of minified tokens to
portions in the original source
so kind of what this actually means is
if we look at our source map for our
min.js we get our line 1 column 125.
what the source map will tell us that
you're actually looking at line 9 column
30 of the unminified javascripts
and it will also translate that symbol n
to show thing
so now we're kind of making some
progress we can we can apply a source
map to our our minified source we see
this exception
random exception we're able to actually
get back what we would have if we
weren't running minified source
but the caveat is that source maps
require
three three things to actually be useful
uh one is the file name obviously the
script that it's coming from
the line number
and the column number
without all three of these pieces of
information a source map is literally
useless there's nothing you could do if
you just have a line number you cannot
you have line one what are you gonna do
with line one
um
and unfortunately column numbers are
actually pretty rare to get
uh it's getting better through modern
chrome
and firefox oddly gives you the column
number of the top frame
none of the other frames it only gives
you the top frame
don't know why but that's the way it
works
internet explorer just good luck
no idea you get terrible things from
that
winter dot on air also has only a line
number as we originally pointed out
so if we look at this line in firefox so
we have one of our frames we can see
that we get everything except
that nice little column number that we
would like
i'm not even going to explain internet
explorer but if you want to have some
fun and uh torture yourself please feel
free to explore this stuff in internet
explorer because it's
it's a it's a riot
also this this air.prototype.stack being
a string really really sucks we need to
keep track of all these different
regular expressions we need to keep
track of the evolution of all these
browsers
and the bottom line is there is no
standard around this so we can't just
come up with one regular expression that
solves the problem for everybody we have
all this feature detection we have to
determine what version of firefox to
parse the you know that specific
exception out
um
we just have a mess
so va came out with something a while
ago that is really really interesting i
don't know if this is necessarily the
best option out there but it's probably
by far the most useful today
unfortunately it's only v8
but they've introduced
what they call this call site api and
this is similar this is access to these
raw frames
so if anyone that has worked with python
and debugged actual stack traces in
python
in python you're able to literally
traverse the frames programmatically
you're able to walk up the tree
and within that tree you're able to
access all the local variables in each
of the frames so i can say what was the
previous call which would be analogous
to arguments.caller
you could walk up this tree and you
could say what functions were in this
scope
you can walk up the next tree or the
next frame you can say what functions
are in this scope
and this is extremely useful so we can
see that when we got into the show thing
function we may see that something was
undefined but we don't know why it was
undefined because we don't have the
variable that was actually passed
through we don't have access to these
local variables
so this callside api is is starting to
head that direction i don't know if the
ability is there to actually do all the
local variables but it's it's getting us
so that we can avoid parsing these stack
traces
so what it introduces kind of as as the
basics is this aired up repair stack
trace
and this aerodynamic repair stack trace
is a global callback which for what it's
worth is probably a pretty terrible idea
as well because people conflict with
this
um
what you do with this repair stack trace
is you're able to tell the engine how do
you actually want to parse the stack
trace
so the default
callback to airedup repair stack trace
is what we would see in v8 it's the
string representation of what our frames
were
but since it's been exposed we can
actually use this to our advantage we
can tell v8 how to transform these raw
call site objects into
what we want as the
error.prototype.stack property
or we can actually not parse them at all
which
is actually what we want to do
so in this case of a callback that we
passed to aired up repair stack trace we
get uh
two arguments are passed through the
actual error object and then the frames
if we just simply return the frames from
this
we have access to the raw call side
objects
error.stack is no longer a string
so if we if we want to
loop over all of these frames we have
access to these getter functions
like get function name get line number
get column number
and now we don't have to parse regular
expressions
so this is a very good step in the right
direction um
basically this is probably the only the
most useful information you can get out
of it there's a bunch of other
functions you can get out of it
but i think this is at least heading in
the right direction the problem that we
have with the errored up repair stack
trace is again like i said because it's
a global
so if one thing is trying to do
something different with this error that
prepares actuaries and you're trying to
do something different you have
conflicts so you need to do this
roundabout logic of setting it to
some variable overriding what it is and
inside your callback call this function
to get the the functionality
but again because we're accessing this
dot stack off of these errors we we get
into a lot of funky race conditions so
in practice
this ends up not being too useful if you
do anything in node and you work with
coffee scripts coffee strip is a really
good example
they override this aired up repair stack
trace to give you a better dot stack
representation um so you can utilize
that when you're when you're debugging
what happens is if you try to inject
this you are now conflicting what
they're doing so either you're going to
break
what they're doing or they're going to
break what you're doing
so error objects are actually are pretty
cool so we have a much better use of
these as opposed to these string stack
traces how do we actually collect these
differently
we have this lovely try catch
so very simple we have something like
this we have we have our function we're
calling do stuff and we want to catch
the error and then in our ideal world we
want to log this error
and then we want to re-throw the error
the reason why we're re-throwing the
error is because to us this is an
uncommon exception we don't know how to
handle this our program should not
continue executing after an exception
has happened so we want to re-throw it
until we fix a bug
so the fun part right here is this log
error so it once we're able to catch the
exception we're actually able to extract
all this information and do something
very very useful with this with this
error object
but try catch is not very very scalable
um you it involves you having to predict
where your code is going to break you're
going to wrap every function in a try
catch and hope that you know you've
actually wrapped the right thing
and if you don't it's going to bubble
back up to window down iron and you're
back to where you where you started with
so what we need to do is we need to wrap
everything
so we need to wrap something in in uh
i guess what we call in python is a
decorator but some just type a function
that calls your other function
so you just call this wrap function and
pass the argument of the function you're
actually calling and this would do the
magic for you in a very generic way
so
this looks is the only thing we had to
change is this first line we just wrap
our entire
uh outer function with a wrap
uh there's gonna be some caveats with
that because that obviously is within
the current stack so anything that you
call as an async callback is not going
to be within the stack so you have to
wrap all of the uh your async callbacks
as well in this wrap
so that sounds pretty cumbersome as well
so
uh okay the last thing i want to touch
on real quick is sentry
so as i talked about that i'm a core
contributor century
and we have this library to go along
with century called raven.js
uh so raven.js job is to do all these
terrible things for you
we do this through means of monkey
patching we patch libraries we patch
into
libraries exception handlers so for
example angular has this global callback
which is effectively their windowed on
air
we inject into all these things and we
try to capture all these things for you
and then we send that along to a server
so we monkey patch we also monkey patch
the native objects so we monkey patch
set timeout set interval like it gets
pretty obtrusive but
it does this job
the raven parses the error reports the
information to the central sensory
server the sentry will fetch your source
maps and give you a nice clean view of
your error so if you publish your stuff
and you have your source maps as well we
will see the exception and we say hey
here's the source map let's actually
make this pretty and if your exception
has the line number and the column
number we can actually give you
a view that looks something like this
so this would be a view inside sentry
and we can see that we had some
exception we could actually see the nice
full stack that you should get if you're
trying to debug this yourself but the
nice thing is that you didn't actually
do this yourself this was something that
a user did this user invoked this error
somehow we get alerted and we saw this
in in century
so i'm kind of calling out that i would
like to help make this stuff better um
and by this i mean exception handling in
browsers i would like to see if there's
some way to get standards going on or
trying to make this call site api or
something that makes makes this process
better
um exception handling should be pretty
simple python is by far probably the
best example of this uh
in my opinion
i want to help with this process i want
to be involved in mozilla tickets i want
to help firefox get to par with how
these things work and i want to
understand why maybe some of these
decisions were being made
so to kind of summarize i have a few
references of uh of these projects that
i've talked about so uh obviously
century raven jazz then there was this
browser stacks project that we put
together which was uh really interesting
what this does is it uses sauce labs to
call
to capture a call stack across every
single browser they support so if you
want some laughs
check that out we have iphones internet
explorer every single browser
they all literally do something
completely different
there's also a really nice library
called stacktrace.js that helps
do some parsing and do some logic that
i've talked about
zone.js is really interesting zone.js
kind of does a lot of what raven.js does
but zone.js takes that to an extreme it
literally monkey patches everything and
gives you these crazy contexts for uh
so every so nothing really gets to win
it on air every execution has its own
context that is captured
and then also there's documentation for
that new
uh javascript stack trace api the call
site api
um
that's it so
apparently i'm told that we don't have
we don't do questions anymore so
someone will please pull me aside later
and
i can talk about this stuff for a really
really long time
so
you